add crafting and research stations in
your Outpost to utilize any resources
you find or already have
mod your weapons to adapt them to your
playstyle different weapon sites and
Scopes larger magazines a selection of
grips and barrels different ammunition
like Explosive Rounds
all you stealth players out there will
surely need a suppressor
you can also choose to go Hands-On with
melee weapons
always a delicate balance between like
what's realistic what SIM and what's
Hollywood and I think we sort of err on
the side of like what's fun for the
player
the overhauled our combat
it's more Dynamic the animations are
more fluid
it just feels great
we probably have more mods and more
weapons in this game than
I want to say any other game we've done
before
there's a lot of variety
upgraded gear is just one of the many
factors to pay attention to when
engaging in combat you may need to
switch things up based on your
environment
gravity is different for each planet and
boost packs are excellent for getting
around
and for giving you an edge in combat
[Music]
sometimes you'll even feel like you're
flying
[Music]
zero gravity environments pose a
different challenge firing a ballistic
weapon in zero g will actually push you
backwards
energy weapons on the other hand offer a
more stable shooting experience
[Music]
we also have mag weapons
these are high-powered electromagnetic
induction ballistic arrays each Barrel
has its own targeting laser and can dish
out some serious damage
whether you want to get up close and
personal with your own two Fists
or you like more compact weapons like
pistols and submachine guns
or maybe you prefer something bigger
starfield's got you covered
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign